غير بعيد عن العاصمه الايسلنديه ريكيا فيك
تقبع محطه هيليشيدي للطاقه الحراريه
الارضيه التي تعد الاكبر في البلاد وثاني
اقوى محطه في العالم
لكنها ايضا منشاه فريده من نوعها بالنظر
الى كونها تحول ثاني اكسيد الكربون الى
صخور الغير ضاره تثمر في اعماق الارض وتعد
هذه المحطه التي تحمل اسم اوكا ثمره
تعاونين بين شركه كلاينكس سويسريه لمحطات
احتجاج الكربون من الهواء مباشره
قالت شركه كلاين واكس ان استخرج الثانيه
اكسيد الكربون من الهواء بشكل موثوق
وخزنته في الارض بشكل دائم لاول مره نيابه
عن العملاء الذين يدفعون الثمن بما في ذلك
شركه مايكروسوفت
واضافت كلايم واكس وهي شركه الناشئه انشات
عام 2009 ان منشاتها في ايسلندا نجحت في
ازاله ثاني اكسيد الكربون من الغلاف الجوي
وحقنه في الارض حيث سيحول تدريجيا الى
صخور
انسايد
الانتقائيه للغايات داخل حاويات التجميع
الخاصه بنا والتي تلتقط جزيئات ثاني اكسيد
الكربون وبمجرد امتلاء الفلتر نغلقه ثم
نسخنه الى 100 درجه مئويه يطلق ثاني اكسيد
الكربون مره اخرى ثم نسحبه من حاويات
التجميع الى ما نسميه قاعه العمليه
وتعد كلايمبكس الشركاتي بما في ذلك
مايكروسوفت وسترايب وشوبي فاي من بين
العملاء الذين اشتركوا بالفعل في خدمات
ازاله الكربون المستقبليه لتعويض عن
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري
4000 طن من ثاني اكسيد الكربون سنويا
الخطوره لتغير المناخ فقد تؤدي تقنيات
احتجاج ثاني اكسيد الكربون من الهواء
وتخزينه دور المحوريه المقبله